Welcome everybody to another zoom call just want to point out as I do always to go to the member site for announce but so there's several new announcements and several changes on the zoom call or excuse me on the member site.
You have now a new lower fee for follow up phone visits $135 for 15 minutes now and you can self schedule so right below that right below this what's new on the member site is this self scheduling button.
So you can just you fill out the request form the info form and you self schedule is close right to my calendar schedule and you could pick a time that works for you you can schedule yourself.
It makes it simple so you're thinking about scheduling on the weekend and oh I got a call on Monday you don't have to do that anymore you can just schedule yourself.
Remember that if you fill out a subscription for your supplements there's a 5% discount on all the subscriptions.
And please remember to fill out the cheek swab request form that's at bottom of that's on the cheek swab page and it's on the members home page so please do that.
We also on our website we have a schedule now page where you could schedule from the website to if you didn't go to the member site for some reason you're just looking on your phone and you don't have your password to the members idle.
Just go to the website and you can schedule from the website to also watch some of the new videos have been promising that I'm going to get videos done on lab interpretation on standard lab interpretation sense.
You know most of you are getting a CVC and a complete metabolic panel and some other labs I will have videos on all standard lab interpretation so it'll help you understand what you're getting sense often we're finding that you're getting very little interpretive value from.
The doctor who requested the labs talked to somebody in a day that they said that they were leaving the visit with the oncologist and she had to say what about my labs you had done and he said oh he didn't even know that he had requested labs or remember that he requested labs hold them up and basically brush them off with no interpretation whatsoever when she had some.
Major things going on in those labs if you have anemia this is where fighting common patterns you know it's not uncommon for somebody with cancer to have anemia if you have anemia and your doctor is it requesting labs at least on a monthly basis oftentimes it should be more appropriate to request them on a weekly or a monthly basis if the person has.
Pretty severe anemia and they are not doing that to watch the anemia that's just that's just not good that's borderline practice where they're not keeping an eye on that because that can cause a lot of ill health and just not a good thing to not keep an eye on you need to be watching that so make sure you're getting you know your doctor if you're using your doctor to request labs so that you can get.
It covered my insurance make sure that you are requesting them frequent enough remember labs just like any other test is a test it's a static picture in time and it's best to look at a you know a more vibrant picture which is going to say which is going to look at those values over time so you need.
Subsequent lab testing in order to look at those values there's some things you don't need that when you're looking at antibodies or something like that but typically when you're looking at a CBC and a complete metabolic pedal you need a picture over time to need subsequent tests and retests therefore to look at those lab values to really know how to see your progress or.
The direction of things are going so so important so watch the new videos in the lab section.
I've also got blog post them as well and soon within the next few weeks i'll have videos on just about every lab test that you could get and i think i'm helpful for you to not only to understand them to understand the interpretation of that but also to understand indeed.
For requesting those into the need for running those so you know it's often I hear from people that why do I need to run those the doctor said they're all normal.
The one video that I created is for is an explanation of what the difference between.
Normal lab values are and what your oncologist or your doctor might think is normal and what functional lab values are or optimal lab values are there's a distinct difference in that we want to catch.
This is before it becomes an emergency will visit so watch that video it's in the lab section.
And it's on the number of the courses and it's on our it's on our website in the blogs so i don't get to listen to me but stomach through it put on a set of ear months and and.
Get a glass of bourbon and sit down and interpret lives for those that just jumped on reminder you can know self schedule all your follow up calls right here it's right on the main page.
Of the member site it's also on the schedule now page on the website that's a new page on the website.
Okay reminder to look at the blogs i'm going to talk about some of those in these questions that were asked first question that came in I was wondering about using an electric blanket with the right machine ball under the blanket is there a problem of doing that i've concerned about the wavelengths in the electricity running through the blanket.
So there is not a problem with using an electric blanket or an electric heating pad.
With the right machine it won't interrupt the frequencies the dirty electricity or the EMS that you might get from the electric electric heating pad or electric blanket are going to be far surpassed by the right frequencies so there's not a problem there.
There's argument though whether there's health benefits that can or health negative effects that can take place using an electric blanket.
Now there's people on one side of the spectrum that says that it's very bad for you because it's creating a different circuit that can affect your bodies electric field and using an electric blanket is not good for you.
And then there's people on the way on the other side of the spectrum that says that's a bunch fully nonsense of much new page weirdos i fall probably in the middle of that i don't use electric blanket.
Because I just I'm concerned about the EMS production of the electric I never we don't have electric blankets i've never been able to test it with the EMS meter but you know there's concerned there.
The reason why I like our electric heating pads that we sell is because they use those those.
You know those.
Terminally discs in them so they're not producing EMS like a regular heating coiled heated pad is so you're getting some.
A better wavelengths in that that you are getting from a coil TV.
because they're crazy to death.
They have, you know, you do want to investigate maybe
why you would need to use an electric blanket.
Do you have a quick way to over these
and all these lab videos.
But, you know, what would be reasons
for why I'm cold all the time and I'm freezing
is it because maybe I just keep my temperature down
and where I spouse likes the temperature down
in the house and it's very cold.
Well, extra blankets should work for that.
Well, no, I don't care how many blankets
and I am, I'm still freezing.
We need to assess thyroid function
to get it a complete thyroid panel.
Most commonly, though it would be
low blood values as far as red blood cells go
and that is called ademia.
So a CBC, complete blood count would be the test
to analyze that.
If you haven't had blood work for a long time,
consider getting our complete wellness panel.
If you don't have the ability to get insurance coverage
through getting your doctor to order it,
our complete wellness panel has CBC,
complete metabolic panel, multiple other tests
that are a great value and a complete
thorough thyroid evaluation and it's $132
plus whatever gets paid for your blood drop,
pretty darn inexpensive.
So consider getting that done,
but no, it will not affect the right frequencies.
I unexpectedly needed a blood transfusion a few weeks ago
and my hemoglobin levels were very, very low.
So why you have to go hemoglobin levels?
That's part of ademia.
So 7.7 is very low and I highly recommend
that if a person has those kind of levels
that getting a blood transfusion is the right thing to do.
I later call the blood bank to learn
if I could have specific people donate blood for me
like family members for future possible transfusions.
My motivation in part was to have people
who did not take a COVID vaccine donate to me directly.
The blood bank makes it very difficult
to have a donation directed specifically to the woman told me
that the vaccine is not in the blood,
but then said that they do not even test for this.
My question is, do you think this is true?
That the vaccine material mRNA DNA do not circulate
in the bloodstream,
therefore are not a concern
when receiving a blood transfusion for an unknown donor?
Well, my opinion is that it is in there
and it does affect you.
And we did breach this question a while back.
After the vaccines came out,
people were requesting non-vaccinated blood.
There was some blood banks that did separate that out
with questionnaires from the patient
that were testing the blood.
They were asking the patient's questions
where you vaccinated that blood did get separated out.
I don't know if every blood bank has that availability.
Obviously it doesn't because we just experienced that.
I don't know that even the blood banks
that did have that separation of that availability
still have that availability.
Maybe if you were in the 1% elite,
you could get anything you wanted.
I just saw that the 1% elite that were traveling
to Davos to the World Economic Forum's climate change summit,
that's coming up, are all requesting demanding
non-vaccinated pilots to fly their private jets.
They won't fly with vaccinated pilot pilots.
So I don't want to offend anybody that's listening
to this that did get the COVID vaccine.
But if you listen to me long enough,
I think that was a great mistake.
There's very big dangers in that COVID vaccine.
There's dangers in any vaccine.
This one is the worst.
Followed closely by a few others.
But this is a horrible vaccine.
It's not even a vaccine.
It is a DNA danger tool is what it is.
And it is, I just, it's, you know,
you are exposed, even if you never got the vaccine,
you're still probably if testing was available
to know if there's mRNA or this DNA fragments
from the vaccine in your blood.
I'd probably test positive for it, you would too.
Even if you didn't get a transfusion
and didn't get the vaccine,
because there's so much cross-tamination
and because there's so much contamination
through, you know, anybody that you come in contact with.
So, you know, I'm not sure that we're not all contaminated.
But then you have to weigh out the pros and cons of,
okay, do I not get a blood transfusion,
which could save my life and really help me
get over this giant hump that I'm dealing with
so that I can continue on with other treatment.
If I was in your situation, I would probably get the blood.
There's, you, like I've told you in the past,
you'd have a gun to my head and I would still say no
to the COVID vaccine.
So, it is a concern for those that are trying
to be more diligent at, you know,
and have both physiological reasons and moral reasons,
not to be exposed to this vaccine.
But there's some things that are beyond our control
and there's nothing to do.
Last week I submitted a question asking what you recommended
combat night sweats since the first night,
I started taking the adaptation
because that's I suggested taking adaptogens.
I went from changing clothing up to four times per night
to not needing to change once
in a smaller amount of sweat around my neck and upper chest.
Incredible improvement.
I am beyond grateful.
Thank you.
Well, you're welcome and you need to thank the Lord
because I didn't have the answer to that question
before I answered it.
And sometimes God just gives us wisdom
and so praise God, give him all the glory.
I have been getting a loop run injection every three months,
seven months, seven months total so far,
four metastatic prostate cancer and PSA and PSA levels
as consistently registered less than zero point one.
Recently my oncologist has suggested
also let's back up this a little bit.
I did not look this person up who did this
but if your PSA is less than zero point one,
it's a good possibility they had their prostate removed.
So when a person has prostate cancer
and they're doing loop run,
if they still have a prostate,
lots of times their PSA won't go this low.
But if you don't have a prostate,
it's your PSA should stay this low when you're doing loop run.
So loop run is an indigent deprivation drug.
So it just removes all your testosterone.
That's what loop run does.
Okay, sorry.
Continue.
Recently my oncologist has suggested
I start taking this other drug
or the four times a day together with a steroid
as this other drug can cause electrolytes to decrease.
If you don't take it with a steroid,
I was told this combination of world drugs
together with loop run injections
can extend the time period that my PSA will stay at a low level.
So understand using an indigent deprivation therapy
drug like loop run, there's several others on the market.
Typically we'll work wonders
to drop a person's PSA don't in the takes.
But it typically just historic use of it
will only keep PSA levels there for two to five years
and then all of a sudden they just start going up.
And they don't know completely why except,
I'll tell you in a second.
Since taking this drug plus predisode
is a lifetime medication what I'm told
someone has to begin this special treatment,
wonder if there's other things I can do.
Well, I did write a blog about this a couple of years ago
because this phenomenon of energy deprivation therapy
working for a period of time and it stops working
has been known for quite some time.
And there's actually data and why they think
it actually happens.
It has to do with the receptors
and the energy receptors that it's working on.
And this is the blog post that I wrote on it.
So go to this blog post.
Because it's been proven that two different things
andograph as an EGCG and I would add
curcumin and Resveratrol to this as well.
Work on that receptor to remove IL-6
interleukin-6 expression at that receptor
and will help a person be able
to get this same benefits from energy deprivation therapy
for a longer period of time without having to take
those other drugs.
And it's pretty easy to get that those these nutrients.
And in this blog post, I actually tell you
exactly what to take to get this.
So read that blog post.
Just search in the blogs.
I can write there.
The blogs just search right there
for prostate cancer,
hormone health and regulation.
And you see what I wrote about it.
I was reading this Mercola article on Extensive Thin.
This section of anti-concert benefits confusing.
So she quotes this article,
the person asking this question.
Exerts its anti-proliferative.
So anti-proliferative means it's not causing
proliferation of cells.
It's not really helping with cancer cells,
not proliferating, not growing, not replicating.
And then this is the confusing point anti-apoptotic
and anti-invasive influence via different molecules
and pathways, including signal transducer
and activator of transcription.
Three, nuclear factor capa, light chain enhancer
and activated B cells.
That's nuclear factor capa beta
and proxysome proliferation activated receptor gamma.
That's called p-par gamma.
Hence, extensive and shows great promise
as a chemotherapeutic agent in cancer.
Now the confusing part is this right here.
This is the question.
How is it anti-cancer if it's anti-apoptosis?
Well, I did pull up that article
and you kind of have to read the article.
So the article goes into explaining
that actually extensive and works on two different
apoptotic channels.
I think I've written some blog posts on what's called intrinsic.
The intrinsic apoptotic pathway,
that's the pathway that takes place inside the cell
if something is damaging the cell
and can fire this capsaic pathway inside the cell
and cause the cell to go through
normal program cell death.
And then there's an extrinsic apoptotic pathway
that is stimulated by something outside the cell
attaching to different receptors on the cell membrane
stimulating the capsaic pathway
and causing apoptotic, the apoptosis to take place.
Well, this actually takes place,
a good part of the article is kind of arguing back and forth
there's evidence that apoptosis takes place.
And both those things, both through the intrinsic
and the extrinsic pathway.
But the key point was this is the way they were to understand
sometimes writers of the studies
are the best at English.
Sometimes when you have quota studies
and you have to correct their English,
it is anti-apoptosis and later in the article it says
that it's anti-apoptotic to healthy cells
but it's pro-apoptotic stimulating both the intrinsic
and the extrinsic apoptotic pathway in cancer cells.
So, yes, a little bit confusing.
You had to dig in and read the article
a little bit deeper says the results obtained by song
among others show that the significant peak
hydrodiploid indicative of apoptosis.
So apoptosis is when a cell goes through these,
these what are called, the lab beans
where it starts to break apart.
So apoptosis is a normal program cell that's enough
to get too deep into the histology
but the cell starts to blab or convolut
in on itself and break apart.
And actually it's a recycling of cell material.
So, cell material, all the, the insides of the cell
is filled with 1000 mitochondria and ribosome
and reticular activating organelles.
All these different organelles, these giant,
I think inside of a cell like inside of,
it's as busy as what's going on in New York City.
You'd hate to have all the benefits
of what's going on in New York City be destroyed
by a nuclear bomb.
That's a different way a cell could die.
A cell could die through the process
which is an unhealthy cell death.
Like if you were poisoned,
that's not normal program cell death.
The cell just breaks apart and all the cell material
spills out and then your body has to deal
with that material and detoxify it
and you can become sick from the cell death material itself
and you can develop, you know, the immune reaction to that
and that's what's called a herb cyber reaction
where the cell just kind of explodes, breaks apart
and you get sick.
That's partly what happens when you do chemotherapy.
It's causing the crisis, it's causing a pathological death
of a cell where apoptosis, apoptosis is not
a pathological death of the cell.
It's a normal program death of the cell
so it goes through different phases of blebbing
to actually recycle the material
and the hypo diploid phase of apoptosis
is part of that blebbing.
Sorry, you probably didn't want to know that.
Detected by flow cytometry,
when the cells were treated with this
so they were purposely treated with an oxidative agent
in order for this to take place, et cetera, et cetera.
And it goes on here, it induces a capsace mediated
mitochondrial apoptosis that's part of the intrinsic
apoptonic pathway.
And then later it says it's regulated
in the game descriptions and how that's actually
happy to cancer cells in this example was with lymphoma.
So in cancer cells, it produces apoptosis in healthy cells
and actually protects from apoptosis, early apoptosis.
And if you read that whole article,
you'd probably better read that it actually protects
from a necrotic death of the cell
would have been a better terminology
because extantism actually acts as an antioxidant.
And they have a whole section, I didn't copy and paste that,
in this article about the antioxidant benefits
of extantism and how that protects against a cell poisoning
because that's what oxidation is.
I recently got another breast thermogram done,
it's my first sense the full body was done
at the clinic two years ago,
the full thermogram two years ago
did not show any activity in the breast.
I was told that this was because frequently my type of cancer
will not show up on a thermogram.
Yes, that's true.
This most recent thermogram, however,
did show activity at the tumor site.
Is this necessarily vascular activity
that is feeding the cancer?
Is it possible that it's inflammation
related to topically applying frankincense
at DMSO every day?
So what we'll show up on a thermogram
is metabolic activity.
So metabolic activity can be cell growth
and replication cells that's gonna increase metabolic activity
and any increase in metabolic activity
is gonna increase heat.
So what a thermogram is reading is heat.
Now thermograms have negatives to them too.
So some breast cancers don't replicate quickly.
Therefore don't produce a lot of heat.
Some cancers, the breast cancer are too deep
to actually have the heat be expressed
on the surface of the body.
Therefore you can't really see about a thermogram.
So it's not highly beneficial
for a colon cancer or something.
But increased vascularization could increase heat.
So that's a possibility.
But certainly doing anything topical on the skin
is gonna increase heat.
So in this case, I would say you know,
if you have been applying frankincense at DMSO
on a daily basis, I'd say you got about 99% chance.
That's what it's fun.
Now if you really wanted to test it,
you'd stop doing that for a period of time
and it's an insurgent period of time
because you don't know how long that that's gonna take.
But at least two weeks before doing it on a thermogram,
but that would be one way to test it.
Okay, let me tell you what's the only,
oh, if you do have our new video site up,
it's not completely organized.
Like I've said before, we're still working on it
but you can go to our new video site.
YouTube has been pulling videos off our site
say that it's missing information.
And my daughter who works at our Instagram channel
is very frustrated because we have over 2000 followers,
which I know that's not that much,
but we just started this.
And she'll put up a video and we get 28 views
and she says this is just impossible.
You know, we should have at least 2000 views.
Well, even our followers are not able to see our videos.
So understand Instagram and Facebook
and YouTube is shadow banning people like me,
especially cancer related things
because it's called medical disinformation.
And if you wanna see our videos in Instagram,
if you're an Instagram user,
you have to go into your settings on Instagram
and allow all videos because it's with the new Instagram update
every Instagram user that's setting this but to filter out
medical disinformation videos, which that's what we fall under.
So we're producing a lot of stuff.
We're getting shadow band on Instagram,
shadow band on Facebook, shadow band on YouTube.
They're taking down our YouTube videos,
pretty soon our YouTube channel's probably gonna be canceled.
And we're getting shadow band on Google.
So that's just so it is folks.
So if anybody does want to give us a testimony,
we greatly appreciate it.
We're trying to let people know who we are
and what we do and it's difficult to do that these days.
Okay questions, which blood test shows
how the immune system works?
I have to find this test and KCEL test.
So the lymphocyte test, CD3, CD16, CD56.
Yeah, these are all tests that you can run to show
the function of the immune system.
Certainly if you just want a general function
of the immune system, you're running a simple CDC panel.
So a simple CBC panel will show your total white blood cell
coat and it will show your differentials.
Now it only shows the differential to lymphocytes,
stutrophils, monocytes, spasophils.
It's not gonna break the lymphocytes down
into their particle cells.
It's not gonna show other immune modulator cells
like all your CD cells.
You have to get a more advanced panel for that.
However, does a person need to get those advanced panels
if they have a diagnosis of cancer?
I do not think you need to get those headbands panels
if you have a diagnosis of cancer.
Those advanced panels are really for a diagnosis
of an autoimmune disorder.
So if you have an autoimmune disorder,
if you think you have a genetic disorder
in what's called your complement factors,
causing the immune issues,
then that can be a good test to get.
Cyrex has what's called a lymphocyte map test
and that breaks.
That's probably your best breakdown
of all your immune cells that you do a screenshot
and show you what that looks like.
That's what the Cyrex lymphocyte map tests for.
That's probably your most your heftiest picture
of testing for immune function would be that.
That test is somewhere around 400 bucks or something like that.
But that's really, honestly, that's that would not necessarily
be recommended for a cancer patient.
It would be more recommended for somebody who has
a immune serious immune dysregulation
and that would be somebody with a serious autoimmune disorder.
That's really what that would be recommended for.
So I, for persons got cancer issues
and they're trying to get their immune system
to function to help destroy the cancer.
It's not that's not really what you're,
this is a diagnostic tool to see what's wrong.
It's not necessarily things that are correctable
by like using specific immune stimulation.
This is telling us what's wrong
because of something in immune dysregulation
that's going out in the body
and because of an autoimmune issue.
So I don't know that I would recommend that,
but if you wanted on a strict curiosity
to see all your total natural killer cell counted percentage
and all your cytotoxic,
natural killer cells and percentage of those
and total natural killer cells, your CD, 56, 16,
T cells, all this fun guru stuff,
you can certainly run that.
And that's in the store, our lab store.
I read that DHEA is an estrogen precursor
which made me think about my last touch test
before cancer diagnosis, my results show
that my estrogen was low, but my DHEA was very high.
For my age, does it follow then
that the DHEA was not turtied into estrogen?
Well, if I have a video on the touch test,
I'm pretty sure, but let's look at what that would look like.
What that would look like.
I'll give you the example of a touch test here.
So here's what a touch test looks like.
You're looking at all your hormones.
Pregnant alone, breaks down the progesterone.
Pregnant alone breaks down the DHEA.
DHEA is a hormone that's made into your
adrenal gland, DHEA-S is followed.
That's different than DHEA.
DHEA breaks down the DHEA-S, then testosterone.
And then that can convert to these estrogen.
So the most concerning estrogen
is something that drives cancer
is this four hydroxyesterone.
This one right down here.
This is one that can damage DNA.
This is the one that most commonly attaches
to the estrogen receptor on the cell membrane
that can block apoptosis.
I remember I said that there's different
two different apoptotic pathways,
but this is blocking is the extrinsic apoptotic pathway.
So when you have estrogen receptor positive
refer to positive cancer.
It's this four hydroxyesterone that's attaching
to that receptor of the cell membrane of the cancer cell.
So it is a cause of cancer.
It's just blocking apoptosis.
Now this can build up in the cell and damage
the nucleus of the cell.
So anything that builds up in the cell
can be a cause of cancer.
Now you can't test for intracellular hormones.
So that's not available,
but you want this being tested for
is whether you have estrogen positive,
estrogen receptor positive breast cancer.
So it's being affected from the extrinsic apoptotic pathway.
So the question is can excess DHEA cause
a build up of these estrogens?
But what you mentioned without looking at your test,
this is just an example test.
I just pulled out the internet.
This isn't anybody's that I know.
Is that you said your estrogens were low?
These are the three main estrogens that are
your main functional estrogens.
And then they break down into the 16 hydroxy,
four hydroxy, two hydroxy,
and through methylation and the CO and T gene
break down to a methylated estrogent esterone.
And then your body utilizes these and gets rid of these.
But if these three were low and this was low,
but your DHEA was high,
could that have been a precursor to your cancer?
And I'd say no.
No, I mean, I don't think so.
I mean, if this was high,
DHEA is high, typically is a side
that's part of your stress response.
So again, I'll have a video on this for better understanding.
But in general, your DHEA is
extruded by your adrenals
and it's part of your stress response.
So if a person is under acute stress,
or even chronic stress for a long time,
they still could show elevated DHEA.
Chronic stress over a greater amount of time
you ended up with adrenal burnout.
And then typically you have low DHEA and low cortisol.
But then that's what that first part of the first page
in the back to it, of the first page of the Dutch test,
also does a cortisol,
you do a salivary cortisol test over time
as well, you take four different samples.
Now, this person is showing a depressed cortisol level.
The red is the person's,
this would be the high range.
So if the person's that would be under an acute stress,
there they could be way up here in cortisol.
Now, they're showing a very low free cortisol,
a very high metabolized cortisol.
So they're metabolizing it at the very low free cortisol.
They're under adrenal fatigue mode right here.
Now, this part here is probably
somebody completely different
who's just two things I've grabbed out to look at.
So this one would show if they're in a low level of DHEA.
So maybe they're at a greater degree of fatigue
but they are pretty high levels of E2 at D1
at very, very high levels.
So this is probably on the internet
because it uses an example of somebody
that's a great danger of estrogen
really affecting them, for instance, cancer.
So this is why a person would go on an aromatase inhibitor
and try to get rid of these astrogens.
This would be a person that would probably benefit
from an aromatase inhibitor.
They got very damaging high levels of 400 oxysteroid.
So they should be on at least natural aromatase inhibitors.
But every patient of ours that I've tested,
this has been, these have been really,
these have been the perfect balance.
Because they've been taking natural aromatase inhibitors.
So they're not gonna have the danger of attachment
to that estrogen receptor.
So your question does it follow that then the DHEA
was not turned into estrogen?
Yeah, it does follow that it wasn't turned into estrogen.
I would agree.
Have you heard of high dose melatonin instead
of an aromatase inhibitor?
I think that not.
So the introvert protocol.
No, you could use high dose melatonin too.
That's, you know, I think I have a blog post about it.
I would certainly write about that in my book,
using it anywhere between 60 to 200 milligrams of melatonin.
Before that, normally, if you're trying to get to sleep,
you take three milligrams of melatonin.
So 60 to 200 milligrams is very high dose melatonin.
It doesn't help you get to sleep any better,
but it still will give you some of that advantage
about the same advantages, three to six milligrams well.
But it works on different systems
and it can help with different cancers,
not just breast cancer, not just hormone-related cancer.
Have you heard of bitter melatonin?
Have you heard that they use it extensively
and be it numb for breast cancer?
Yes, I have.
I don't think I included that in my book.
And I don't think I have a blog post about that.
But yes, I've heard of using bitter melatonin.
It's actually in, I'm pretty sure it's in some supplements
that we use.
I could be wrong, though.
But yeah, that's another
nutrient that, let me look it up.
So I know bitter melatonin isn't herb
that is used for decreasing sugar.
So it's in some of our supplements
that we use to help people with diabetes.
But we don't have it as a separate supplement.
I think my cortisol was upside down.
Low and it should have been high and vice versa.
What does that mean?
Well, it certainly means adrenal issues.
So it can be because stress issues.
So remember, the adrenal glands,
as well as the thyroid gland,
secrete based upon nervous system, input
and other hormone input.
So what hormones act on the adrenal glands?
The pituitary.
What is the nervous system that acts on adrenal glands?
The autonomic nervous system.
So if you have perceived stress,
meaning if I didn't even be any real stress,
it's just perceived stress.
It's called worry.
It's another word for it.
You will stimulate a adrenal hormone output.
So understand, stress hormones have a distinct purpose,
a good purpose, a positive purpose.
If you're walking down the street
and somebody comes at you with a knife,
you want to have a healthy adrenal gland
to stimulate stress hormones.
So you can be the daylights out of that,
or run away as fast as you can.
That's going to be a sympathetic stimulation,
sympathetic nervous system is going to be stimulated.
Your parasympathetic is going to be down-regulated
and you're going to be able to fight, fight lightly,
or freeze, or get out of that situation and protect yourself.
But when we have nobody chasing us
and nobody trying to kill us,
but we perceive that like health issues,
or relationship issues,
we just tend to be high anxiety people, person.
So we tend to just, you know,
ruminate on these things.
Then we're stimulating our adrenals
and we're just causing just a lot of adrenal dysfunction.
You can get these upside-down curves.
Now, another issue in a person that has the tendency,
let's say they go,
oh, that's me, I tend to worry about things
and I tend to just overthink things
and I'm just constantly just rolling around
in my head all the time.
And you also have to look at glutamate levels.
And so glutamate is different than glutamate.
Glutamate is a neurotransmitter
that's an excitatory neurotransmitter
and I'm pretty sure I have several blog posts and videos on this
because it does tie to multiple genetic factors.
You can have some genetic issues on your GSH genes.
And your GAN genes that if you have defects on those,
you convert glutamate in your diet,
which is amino acid from, you know, eating foods
that have protein,
you convert it to glutamate quite regularly,
faster than other people do.
And that's why some people tend to be just nervous.
Nellies tend to have more anxiety.
They tend to, you know,
if they're medically oriented,
they tend to be on anti-exiting medication
because they are obsessive compulsive individuals.
Now glutamate is an excitatory neurotransmitter
that is not bad in itself.
That affect people that they have discovered.
People that have higher levels of glutamate
are more intelligent.
They study more.
They don't sleep quite as much
because they're thinking about things.
They're inventors.
They're creative people.
So it's not a bad thing necessarily to have too much glutamine.
But if you are then feeding that pathway excessively,
which what is the worst form of glutamine on your brain
is they can call it monosodium glutamate, right?
And that is just a horrible form of glutamine
that actually fires so strongly in the brain
that it actually burns pathways out.
High correlation between obsessive compulsive disorder people
and glutamate levels in the brain.
So that's where that thing will clear that out perfectly
but trying to really limit any foods
that have MSG is really, really important for those people.
Even things with antivirus colorings
that things can stimulate glutamate
quite strongly.
Sometimes people think it's a dopamine issue
but it's really a glutamate issue, really a big problem.
And it then glutamate excitatory neurotransmitter
fires the sympathetic fires the pituitary fires the adrenal
and it's this whole negative cycle.
That's what I talked about it with this in the corner of the hall
because it's just a huge negative cycle that can burn out.
You really need to get a hold of it
from a spiritual standpoint to do different mental practices
where you're just going to use your prayer and meditation
could be extremely helpful,
getting outside and growing yourself
could be extremely helpful too.
Adaptogens would be the first go to as far as nutrition goes.
Please remind me how many days one should wait
after chemo before doing a cheek swab.
I'd just give it at least 48 hours.
You don't need to really wait longer than that.
Give it 48 hours, I would say.
What are the other questions?
Well, I hope all of you have a wonderful Christmas plan
with your family and that you could just relax
and enjoy family.
We are not closed next week.
We're closed on Monday and we're closed
on Monday the first.
Angie will be gone all the next week.
But anyways, everybody else will be there.
I'll be there.
Merry Christmas.
Have a blessed time.
Remember what the season is for
and we just wish you guys all the best.
All right, love you all.
Bye-bye.